this is the Royal Air Force training
centrifuge at Farnborough and the team
here are going to push me as far as they
are allowed to push a civilian the
centrifuge has been here since 1955 the
device was originally installed for
research purposes although these days
it's used for training as as much it is
for research what it does is recreate
the forces that you feel in an aircraft
for our routine pilot training the first
time pilots go on the centrifuge we
expect them to get up to 5g without a
g-suit and then up to 7g with an anti G
suit now I'm not taking a significant
risk here I'm healthier I pulled a few
G's before and the human body can take
this and the reason we know that is
because in the 1950s the US Air Force
used rocket sleds to push volunteers to
incredible speeds but that
rocket-powered acceleration wasn't the
dangerous or even the really high G part
of the test
see haiji acceleration takes a lot of
incredibly expensive rockets or a big
old centrifuge like this but high G
deceleration all we need for that is a
wall or for something less destructive
like the rocket sleds you use scoops
drop down into a water trough US Air
flight surgeon John Stapp aboard the
rocket sled sonic wind number one holds
the record for the highest sustained
g-force anyone has ever voluntarily and
jawed 25 G for 1.1 seconds with a brief
peak over 46 G and he was badly injured
but he survived and he recovered he
lived to the age of 89 the human body is
an incredible thing particularly because
we didn't evolve for this G tolerance is
something that's innate in all of us
some of us have high G tolerance some of
us have low G tolerance over the years
people's deterrence doesn't really adapt
any shortfall in g tolerance has really
got to be made up by physical desertion
in the g s-- training went over what the
centrifuge doesn't have is much jerk and
jerk is a technical term in the same way
that acceleration is the rate of change
of speed jerk is the rate of change of
acceleration and because it takes time
to spin up and spin down oh here we go
even though the acceleration is high the
jerk here is relatively low about 1g per
second jerk is the difference between a
rocket to space which which might take a
couple of minutes to reach peak
acceleration and
a jet where maneuvers might change the
g-force acting on you in a fraction of a
second and it can go further than that
you can measure the rate of change of
jerk which is called snap or jams the
two derivatives after data called
crackle and pop but they're not all that
useful in the real world as we increase
the G that Tom is exposed to the Bloods
going to be pushed down into his feet
and he's going to have to work really
hard to push that blood back up to feed
oxygen to his brain
to keep him conscious and in real life
we would be expecting that person to be
flying an aircraft whilst doing that we
teach the auntie-ji straining maneuver
which composes of two separate parts
first of all muscle tensing so both the
buttocks and the legs squeezing the
blood vessels to try and get the blood
back up into the chest and the head but
also the second part is a breathing
maneuver which increases the strain in
the chest directly increasing the blood
pressure to the great vessels in the
chest and keeping him conscious and when
you lose blood pressure to your head you
could even lose consciousness and we
term that G induced loss of
consciousness or G lock
Oh
blimey
I lost everything there Wow G lock in
itself is not dangerous but the real
point is when you g lock you're flying
an aircraft so if you're not able to fly
that aircraft
I'm sure you can appreciate that that is
a real problem because of John Stapp and
all the volunteers like him that rode
the rocket sleds there is a lot of
research ah into acceleration on the
human body
how many G's can be withstood four
minutes at a time how many genes can be
word stood for brief moments and how
many committed stood with training that
I clearly don't have rocket scientists
and rollercoaster designers use that
data but there's not much research into
jerk because how do you test it without
also testing acceleration over on the
starship channel I am NOT passing a help
to putting cheese with the blades
aerobatic team and as for this video
thank you so much to all the team at the
RAF Center of aviation medicine to the
team at kinetic and the team at starship